So far we've decided the response
we should send back based on
the request URL.
But in the real world,
we need to be more dynamic than that.
For example, the page can send
a request which we intercept and
then send to the network.
But rather than just sending the
response back, we could look at it and
do something else.
For example,
let's respond with a network fetch for
the request, just as the browser would
do if we left it to its own devices.
The fetch method will take a full
request object as well as a URL.
As we saw earlier,
fetch returns a promise.
With promises, you can attach
a .then call back to get the result,
if the operation was successful.
Whatever we return in this callback
becomes the eventual value for
the promise.
This means we can look at
the response ourselves, and
if the responses are 404 Not Found,
we could respond with our own message.
Otherwise, we return
the response we received.
.catch is similar to .then, but .then is
for success and .catch is for failure.
Fetch will fail if it can't make
a connection to the server at all,
which includes offline.
So when that happens,
we can respond with our own message.
So now, if we make sure our
force update is enabled and
hit refresh,
everything is back to normal.
But if we go to a page that doesn't
exist, we get our custom message.
If we take the server down,
go offline, and
refresh the page,
we get our custom message for that too.
We can create complex rules for
requests,
trying to get a response from multiple
sources, and reacting to the results.
And we can do that on a request by
request basis using JavaScript.
You can even go to the network, and
if that fails,
get something else from the network.
In fact, this sounds like something for
you to do.
Mike, come in, Mike.
Can you hear us?
>> Yes I can.
>> How about a task chaining
two fetch requests together?
>> Yeah, let's do it.